[Music]
today um reaching I are going to run you
through added surface data-driven
insights from the G Street advent
platform and also tying in with bigquery
so we're going to see if we cannot stop
we're sort it when you get the slides up
we first give you some background and
why this is important right so we you
saw today at the keynote you know a lot
of the speakers talking about moving to
the cloud in peril there's so much more
data now that's in the clap and it's
great that they're stayed in the cloud
but it's only really useful if you can
get insights from it and if it is
actionable that's what we're going to
talk about today specifically we're
going to zoom in on security talk a lot
of smaller else but I think security is
a key piece because if you really think
about it that's very much what is on
CIOs minds these days so one of the
things that having detailed reporting
does is it allows you to move from a
sort of standardized security posture to
one's tailored for your organization so
if you think about a standard set of
policies that you might have you know
that might be either too permissive or
too restrictive for your organization or
might be both the same time for
different groups of your organization by
having detailed recording an insight you
can determine where you need to tighten
the controls and where you're okay and
so we're going to run you through that
and the way that we do that is to
reporting and it allows you to do a
number of things and numbers allows you
to assess where your risk points are
we're going to show that in a few
different element it also very much
importantly allows you to make timely
intervention so when you detect us a
problem you need to be able to act on
that and you'll to do something specific
you can set security controls you can
also set up the LP which allows you to
control you know you're sharing policy
based on content and based on teams and
things like we're gonna talk about that
and audit allows you to understand you
know ongoing incidents and respond to
them really really quickly and finally
we look outside security the other piece
for reporting is truly understand how
organizations are adopting the chief
sweet right need a sanda keynote
everyone's talking about well you know
how did you see transforms your
organization will only really transforms
your organization if you use it what we
found it a lot of customers is that you
know you'll have certain pockets where
they're really using a lot of a lot of
collaboration it's another pockets
whether or not a lot of times that
indicates that it may be some training
or some warnings need to flow from one
area to the other so that your whole
organization is really taking advantage
of all the benefits of going going
cognate up with the key three and so
there are three main elements to our
reporting platform it's got
comprehensive data what I mean by that
is you want to go deep and wide across
the g3 products that we've got to all
the logos are many of the logos of the G
so you continue to add more and go why
by covering all the reports and then
having a lot of detail reports we've got
55 usage reports on the admin console 9
audit streams and 18 alerts and all this
is really really increasing until that
provides you know your baseline your key
pieces there and then we want to have an
extensible platform api is that allow us
to push the data out to where you need
it ok so partners can integrate with the
API to provide customized solutions and
we can also send the data over to
bigquery and run some really really
interesting analysis we're going to show
that today and then finally all of that
you're doing all of that not just so
that there's data you're doing it so
that you can get insights
and that you can act on those inside so
we're going to show you how the
reporting system ties into that can
develop insights you can surface and
then you can most crucial as I said act
on them so the three particular types of
reports that reporting platform provides
we've got domain and usage reports got
over 100 metrics in the reporting API in
this area also got on it and what that's
about it that's about getting near
real-time updates on user activity and
across all the corgi sweet acts that I
talked about final piece is alerts
admins can choose from 20 predefined
alerts to create custom alerts on there
for custom alerts on the on its train
and then developers can push alerts in
through the reporting API we should
going to give us an overview of how
reporting is set up in the admin comp
great thanks Alan so agree with everyone
so I'm going to talk briefly about all
our reporting capabilities that we have
today admin console the first important
thing that I want to talk about is on
the domain level so we are admins have
this requirement to see at a domain
level what are the top things that are
going on so our domain level reports are
split into categories the first section
being the highlight section we realize
that admins are very busy people as they
need a quick snapshot of what's
happening inside the company so the
highlights page provides a 360-degree
view of all the important things that
are happening inside the domain right
from what's the seven-day active usage
what's the file sharing status inside
the company are there any users we've
suspended are there any users who are
blocked are there any users who are
nearing the quota and you know that
that's a clue for admin to go and
purchase mahkota so these are like
really important inputs that madman can
get a quick glance off but that's only
good for getting a quick snapshot what
if an admin wants to get a more deep
dive information into each of these
different applications so for that we
have aggregate reports aggregate reports
provide at a domain level data on each
of the server
so for example if you want to know how
many files exist inside your company how
many files are shared outside the domain
how many a encrypted emails exist in
your company in the in the in a world
where mobile device management is
becoming very important admins would
like to know how many managed devices
exist inside your company broken down by
iOS Android and so on so advocate
reports provide that level of
information where admins can go deep
dive into each of the services each of
the device management attributes and and
even export this information into a
Google spreadsheet or a CSV and do
further drill downs the next category
that I want to talk about is we've
spoken about domain level reports but
what if admin wants to drill down at a
user level for example if you as an
admin want to roll out 2-step
verification inside a company which is a
very powerful way to secure your account
at that stage you want to know which
users are enrolled in 2-step
verification which users are not
enrolled and for those who are not
enrolled you need to inform them and
that's where the user level reports
become very important they provide you
granular data at each user level and we
provide three different views around
user level data so you could have a
security view where you can slice and
dice by all the security related metrics
for example you want to know how many
external applications have my users
installed given that there's a lot of
sensitivity around external third-party
data so that's a very important
attribute the second one could be how
many users have been told in two-step
verification the third one could be are
they installing less secure applications
or not either using security keys other
sharing files outside the domain so
that's the security view you could also
have a pure collaboration and adoption
view of user level reports just to
discover how many users are actively
creating docs how many users are sharing
these files because a company has gone
Google for not just for cost savings but
also to bring about a change in the
culture of in the collaborative culture
and that report helps you discover what
are the collaboration trends happening
inside my company are there specific
users who are not using Doc's as much as
other users
and that's a clue for an admin to
basically go in conduction maybe some
trainings for these users so that's what
makes user level it was very very
important and I want to highlight that
these are very these reports offer a lot
of flexibility you can download these
reports in your google spreadsheet or a
CSV you can do advanced filtering you
can do spotting on top of this data so
there's a lot of flexibility that is
offered the next one that I want to
really highlight is audit all the
reports are great but what if I want to
know what's happening right now inside
my company what if I want to get a real
time update into what files are being
shared outside my company what if I want
to know what third-party apps are
getting installed inside my company
that's where audit comes in audit is the
backbone of all security and
investigation work and we have nine
audit streams that are available in
admin console which cover all the major
chord G suit applications Gmail Drive
calendar groups and you get a real-time
feed into every single activity now
imagine the scale of this feature every
single event that a user is doing inside
a company right from viewing of files to
sharing a file to downloading a file is
all captured to give you some stats we
process almost a billion events a day
just on dry wad it that's the scale that
we are operating at and these events are
used by our admins to troubleshoot when
a security incident has happened these
events are used by partners to build
very advanced tools on top of it so it's
really a backbone of all the security
related investigation work that happens
I also want to highlight we also have a
device audit so you can now see every
time I device gets routed every time a
new there's a OS update on your device
so you can get a real-time speed on that
as well the next vertical here is
alerting we realize that admins are very
busy people they cannot come to reports
and keep checking what's happening
that's where alerts come in we've
offered a set and forget' experience
where address can simply come choose
from one of the 18 predefined alerts for
example suspicious logins just go and
turn on suspicious login on your manage
alerts section and you will know
whenever we detect
any suspicious activity and we apply a
wide range of intelligence signals to
detect whether there is a suspected
hijacker who has come into your domain
so we use that information you could set
alert on say a change of dr settings
that's very important especially if you
have delegated super atom
responsibilities to other delegated
admins and you want to keep a tab on
what the other delegated admins are
doing so predefined alerts of a great
way to be aware of what's happening
inside your company and make timely
intervention avoid any security breaches
to happen and if you have a very custom
requirement where you want to track a
very specific event or a specific file
that is also possible so you can go to
it dr audit or any of the other audit
stream select do the filtering on the
left side and then set an alert on top
of it that's where your custom alerts
coming i also want to talk a little bit
about the reports api now all of this
Tufts that we just spoke about is great
on the admin console you can come run
your reports you can do audit you can do
alert but what if i have a very specific
use case in that my company needs to
achieve what if my CIO has come to me
and said create a collaboration
dashboards for our company what if my
CIOs come in told me that ok create a
security dashboard for my company this
is where it's very important for us to
give all of this data to you which you
can use and derive programmatically and
build whatever you want to build for
your company or have this API give it to
partners and we have a lot of talented
partners on our Google Apps Marketplace
who have done great things with the
reporting in audit API and build
advanced use cases to meet a large
customers so reporting API is very
powerful mechanism to get over 100 over
100 matrix through and through push
notification you can create workflows
built on on this particular API we have
about 2 NE plus partner integrations and
I will briefly talk about one such
integration which is better cloud so
they have done a good job of using the
reporting API to build a two-step
verification reporting interface they
also have an ax apps Explorer interface
but you can discover third-party apps or
track water users so this is just one
example there are lot of other partners
on google apps marketplace or integrate
this API and it's helping them meet
sophisticated use cancels like dlp
custom workflows and so on but this I
will hand it back to accuracy so yeah so
there's an overview of admin reporting
but let's uh let's try to put this into
context with some specific examples and
so you know as admins you know we hear
sort of two general classes of requests
from CIOs CEOs two security officers
basically you've got how do I secure my
user is my domain my company so you've
got security and risk management and
then how do I ensure that you know my
visitors are as productive as possible
what I'm actually transforming my
culture by moving to cloud and that's
where we come in to uses an adoption
reporting in to do this we can use our
audit logs now the audit logs provide
near real-time access to events that are
occurring so we can use those to detect
what's going on and then we can set
appropriate policies and rules on to
protect it data in the domain now admins
can slice and dice autodata and it's um
in a number of different ways and we're
going to go over that now and so these
things like we've got here how to track
external file sharing so this is
something that we seen is come up an
awful lot as companies have moved to the
cloud more and increasingly put more and
more sensitive data into drive one of
the first things that you know first
kind of questions that we got was i know
that my data six how do i know what's
going on maybe someone could just be
sharing it everywhere you know before
they have that sense of control when
they had it on premise and when you move
to the cloud you lose that sense of
control and you want to understand
what's going on with your data and
that's what this comes in so reach is
going to show us a quick demo on on how
you can detect us and what kind of
actions you should take thank you thanks
so as I just mentioned file security
around Drive files is really really
critical and we have build some really
advanced tools that i would like to
showcase today and see how admins can
protect the data using these tools so
let's say I'm a user and I my manager
shared this sales forecast document with
me and said hey do some additional
enhancements to this file and I want to
work on this from home and my company is
restricted access from home so what I'll
do is I'll i do I share this file I say
anyone with a link so that I can go back
home and do this can edit save so I
haven't put Mackle also have been very
smart here so my name doesn't show up in
the sharing list and then let's see what
the admin sees now i'm the admin i'm
going to the reporting section
and I will check dry wad it
so there you go I just have got an alert
over here saying the confidential sales
plan has been shared and when I go to my
email I was also i've also got an email
saying this user has changed the link
sharing visibility from private to
anyone with the link now this is a red
alert for me as an admin I have a user's
will shared something confidential to
anyone with a link and this can lead to
large-scale security breaches because
anyone who has a link a link is almost
like a password so anyone who has the
link can go into the file so I go back
to my admin console I click on this file
and first and foremost I can go back and
change this option so that this file is
secure now I've done this but this is a
reactive step I can't do this for every
single file so what is the solution as
an admin that i can get my mental peace
and set policies in control so that my
users don't do these accidental mistakes
right like they don't put the security
of the domain at risk some would like to
show you that you we can now create
rules so i go to the admin console and
this is our brand new drive dlp feature
that we recently announced and as an
admin i have a list of predefined
templates drive data loss prevention
templates that i can choose from or i
can create from a blank template so i
select one of them i can rename
and I can do a host of other things here
I can while I'm creating this rule I can
either assign it to an organization unit
or even better I can use google groups I
can assign it to a bunch of users inside
Google Brooks and I know I avoid this
request from a lot of customers that
they would like to see more and more
policies in the settings being assigned
to google group so this is one such
example where we have done that and on
the content side with the predefined
template i get free templates but i can
customize this and add more out of one
and pick one out of 50 such predefined
templates so use credit card number and
the third feel here is very interesting
drive dlp does a flagging of files and
if i want to be very very precise and
avoid any false positives i will choose
a very high confidence threshold which
not only looks at in case of credit card
number not only looks at the credit card
number but it also looks at some key
words around the numbers they expiry or
name and it does that kind of a matching
so I do that and I'm done with this and
then within the actions I can not only
notify which I was able to do with my
custom alerts but I can actually block
external axis which is a very powerful
way to secure your data based on quantum
scanning so I've done this I've created
and activated this rule and let's see
what happens on the user side so now I
have another doc and I'm real and I've
been asked to work on some of the
sensitivity fight team data and I try to
do the same thing and I'm trying to
share it with say a consumer ID and
there you go i get an error saying this
item contains credit card number and you
cannot share right so this is a great
example of how admins can protect
sensitive data stored inside Drive files
and also audited whenever such
situations happen I just want to
highlight another thing here as an admin
you can
go back to your DLP interface and check
rules audit so you will get a list of
all the files that are matching your DLP
rules and run detailed drill downs on
top of this with this I will go back to
a presentation to the next topic thank
you wishing so shows you really powerful
way to detect and then control third
sharing of dry files and it's really
powerful too quick and that's the key
that was design principle that we had
when we thought about dlp ones make it
not cumbersome really automatic give
users a good experience and give admins
a good experience that's the idea with
all of the security features and so
every time you know as the cloud
continues to get more and more powerful
and you add new capabilities you also
have to secure it in new ways and
third-party data access is a great
example so third party apps are really
powerful you can integrate with the G
sweet using our API and you can extend
the capabilities of G sweet and
integrate d sweet data with your wife or
workflows so that's a great capability
but in on the other hand we've also got
to ensure that will adequately
monitoring and controlling it and that's
where access to third parties and
logging in controls around that come
into play and so we're just going to run
this through a demo of how you would do
that how you would first detect the
behavior you've seeing in third-party
applications is what you expect your
users we doing are they doing this
responsibly or not and then how you can
control that so far we should you can go
to the demo clean thanks does so I'll
quickly show how as an admin I can track
all the third party apps that are
currently being used inside my company
so I'm back to the admin console and I
go to my reporting section and I go to
the user security report which is spoke
about and this report has a problem call
external application so i choose that
as a greater than zero just to scan all
the users will install applications so
there you go it has very quickly told me
these are the users inside your company
who are using external application so i
click on one of them a favor creo and we
go back to his security section inside
Rios page and there you go so I see he
has installed a particular third-party
application I i see this app and I say
okay this not in my approved list so I
say the book and I see revoke now again
this is an example where I have taken a
reactive step my user has gone and
installed it and I have gone in revoked
it this is not scalable we want to give
admin to control where they can set
policies so that users know which apps
to install and which apps are not
authorized now let's see how he can do
that so I'm going to show you a brand
new feature that we are going to be that
is currently in testing interest in
trusted tester to limited customers and
there you go so you have g-suit api
permissions this is a new section that
we have created which shows you what
scopes are currently allowed what data
for missions are currently allowed
inside your domain now notice that you
can also go and check on what
applications are currently being used
inside your company so there you go I am
able to filter by application scope what
apps are being currently use inside my
company and I can go back to the
security permissions page and block any
one of them so i say disabled contacts
and it disables contacts so from here on
users will not be able to use apps that
have access to contacts now if there is
a use case where i want to explicitly
allow a particular applications at my
company that's pretty easy too I go to
my installed applications i open this
button and i say trust the moment I
trust this application what what it does
is it starts honoring or allowing any
access done by this particular
application so now admin has created
very safe playground for his users where
they are free to go and use applications
that are authorized request for
applications that are not there in the
trusted list from the admin and admin
can do his due diligence and agree to
give permission so that way this liquid
balance between not stopping the
innovation that's coming through the
third party apps but at the same time
making sure these third-party apps are
using data in a secure manner with that
I will hand it back to Alan I'll just go
back to the presentation great thanks
for you and so that's a really powerful
evidence reset I mean powerful set of
capabilities that ability to balance
allowing innovation giving users what
they want but also controlling away data
flows now let's talk another example
here which is tracking suspicious logins
and acting on those and so you know that
if you think about one of your primary
risks you're going to see as an admin or
as a company it's compromised accounts
and you know a lot of simple ways that
accounts are compromised things like
just very wide passion reuse for quality
passwords the other thing that's present
and has been and continues to be a big
problem in fishing and so you know
basically fake pages that trick users
into putting in their passwords and it's
still an extremely common problem and it
doesn't look like user education is
going to solve that and so it's
something that we have to be really
aware of that there's a lot out either
targeted you know it's kind of spear
phishing attempts where you're going to
cough your individuals or just kind of
broad-based fishing is relatively common
practice and relatively successful and
so obviously as an admin you want to be
able to detect that kind of behavior and
you want to act on it and you know we're
really excited about the capabilities in
this area so rishis can run us through a
quick demoing in that regard and show us
all the things that we're doing there to
prevent hijacking which is obviously a
huge huge problem you're going to see
thanks house so I'll show you what tools
admins have today to track suspicious
logins and then take proactive action
just like how we have seen in the case
of file sharing and third by the apps so
I go back to
recording section where we have an order
stream call log in audit now here you
will see that admins are able to track
in real time what users are logging in
from which IP they are locking in and I
can also filter based on a specific IP
so i can copy-paste an IP and put it in
my dearest and there you go so i am
basically able to understand what IP is
this particular user is doing so now I'm
a little concerned about okay this IP is
unfamiliar what do I what can I do to
prevent such things so I can go back to
this particular user's account and see
if he has used two step verification
because that's a very powerful way to
prevent any phishing attempts so I see
he's not using and and then I can
basically go back to my report which
shows how many users are using two-step
verification so I go back to my security
report and I check two-step verification
enrollment and I say show me all the
users who are not using two-step
verification there you go so now it's
showing me the trending of all the users
who are not using and in my domain I
only have 8 users who are enrolled so
this is a big problem I only have very
few users who are enrolled into several
occasion and I want to enforce it as a
policy to protect my domain so I go back
to the Security section which has the
list of policies I go to the basic
settings and I say okay I want to go and
enforce so there you go so now i have
the screen where i can decide to enforce
2-step verification by oh you so for
example if i want to enforce it on my
vendors I can turn and turn this on and
I can turn it on from a future date
because i want to give some time to my
users to enroll in two step verification
and this is the new section that we have
recently added allowed to step in
fiction methods where admins can choose
not only to enforce 2-step verification
but they can take and bump up the
security further by enforcing only
security keys which is the new way to
actually authenticate for a second
factor which is a very powerful way
because it's uses a hardware so I can
say only security keys and save it so
that's how an admin can protect against
phishing attempts by enforcing 2-step
verification and with this I will go
back the presentation to al right back
to you Alan Thank You Rishi and you know
that showed an example of security case
which is a really unusual feature in the
security world because you know if we're
honest most times security enhanced
security is a kind of a trade-off with
usability right putting extra elements
of security in place kind of degrades
user experience or makes it more of a
hassle for users in security keeps a
really unusual arm area because it
doesn't do that it's extremely easy to
use and it's much easier to use than
other two factor authentication
mechanisms and it's also more secure
because it son fishable you can still do
sophisticated fishing accounts on on
other second factor login mechanisms but
you can't do that on security because of
the hardware connection to the to the
computer which is amazing and it's also
just as I said it's really easy to use
we use them all the time at Google I
think everyone it will use them and we
there's a study up on the ubicool
website who's the manufacturer of these
things and it showed that ghoulish
actually spent four times less than you
know using standard second factor
mechanisms by using these security keys
these little we just pull this out of
you should computer this little guy
right here and you basically just stick
it in your USB port and anytime you want
a two factor auth you just press it and
it's super super useful so let's talk
about admin and if you want who is
watching the Watchers how does
work and this is particularly a
challenge for large organizations that a
lot of times are going to have delegated
admin you can have a number of delegated
admin and it's possible to the delegated
admin you know while delegation is a
really powerful tool it allows you to
spread the load it's also possible a
delegated admins perhaps don't have the
same level training or the same
understanding of the impact of their
actions and for that we've got to keep a
close eye on what the admins are up to
as well so we're just going to show you
a quick example of that sure thanks Adam
so a lot of this venture is very
important for super admin especially
large organizations where there is a
hierarchical structure a lot of
dedicated Adams lot of super admins to
keep a tab on what the new super admins
are doing so I will quickly show you on
how that could work so we have a
delegated admin Sevani who's logging in
into her admin control and she's been
given a services admin role which
basically means she's in charge of
managing settings for each of the
applications so i go to my server
settings I go to my drive and she's been
tasked with reviewing sharing settings
and taking appropriate actions there and
as I go there I have decided to uncheck
this and by mistake I also uncheck
another setting which says warn the user
when you're sharing outside of the
domain so and check it by mistake and I
save it so this is basically changed it
for the entire company and as a super
admin who has all the privileges I can
go back to reporting and check on admin
audit which basically gives you a full
list of all the actions that admins are
doing so there I see that Shivani who's
the admin has gone and changed the
shading outside the domain setting and
[Music]
remove the warning while the shading is
happening and at the same time I've also
got an alert saying that the
setting has been changed by srivalli I'm
not happy about it because I'm the super
admin and this is weaken the security of
my company because she's gone ahead and
removed the warning from users when
they're sharing outside the domain so I
can simply go back look for her username
in the admin console and I see one role
has been assigned to her and I say
manage roles and I uncheck the services
admin role and I say update because I
think she needs some more training so
let's remove her roles for the time
being and she can go back get trained
and then we can trust her with admin
assignment after this is done so this is
how super admins have a very powerful
control through admin audit because
admin audit keeps a close watch on admin
activities that are happening not just
on admin console but even using API it's
a very powerful mechanism to keep a
control so with that I'll just hand it
back to Al great thanks fishy so God
that's given you a high-level look at
some key capabilities in the admin
console around reporting now there's an
awful lot more there but we picked a few
examples it really highlights saying
other key things that you want to focus
in on however we talked earlier that
that isn't the extent of our reporting
an elf strategy we also want to ensure
that we got good integrations right why
an API and the one that we're really
excited about is bigquery and we really
excited about that because of the power
and the flexibility of bigquery now our
large customers have custom and advanced
requirements that we couldn't hope to
possibly meet in a single console
they've got specific compliance needs
they've got risk legal assessments that
they need to do they also want to mix
data from multiple sources and very
importantly they want to be able to
spread the insights out to targeted
individuals in their company not just to
delegated admin right they want to
syndicate out this information and they
want to really really control it and
that's where bigquery
then we've got this connection between
our admin reports are a mundane and is
able to flow into bigquery and what we
she's going to do is he's going to walk
you through a few different scenarios
that are that are showing just the
amazing slice and dice that you got in
bigquery and also the really really
powerful and very beautiful
visualization that is present in de
estudios connected in there as well so
we should want you I'll hand over to you
and you can rush off runs through that
thanks thank you for a highlight like
bigquery integration what we are
offering is adverts can now directly
export data from their admin console to
bigquery and this is really important
because it cuts down the entire effort
to build an application to call our API
and then from api put the data into
bigquery for this is a direct route that
admins have and just to tell you a
little bit about the feature itself it's
secure because when you go to admin
console and even as it looks at the
signed in admin credentials and only
shows those bigquery projects where this
admin has editable rights on so that it
he cannot take this data to any other
bigquery project it is pretty scalable
and it's one check enablement so the
configuration is pretty lightweight and
and after this push is done admins can
use bigquery to write scalable custom
queries or they can create their own
reports using data studio so i will
quickly show you what this report looks
like and so let's see one such report so
there you go so there is this report
which admin can create for
collaborations so this shows how
different users inside the company are
collaborating across different
applications very beautiful very custom
and it's very easy to build similar to
this I can do another report which is
which shows your comparison between
different OU's so this is a classic cio
stuff where you want to compare
different teams how different teams are
using the different google products and
i can customize this by choosing
specific oh you so na is North America
actually
North America and I want to compare that
with email so there you go so as a CIO I
am able to compare how different teams
inside my company are able to compare
usage across different across different
Google products there is also another
important report that i can create
around security so this report shows me
how files are being shared broken down
by visibility so whether it's external
external outside the domain internal and
I can break it down and I can run some
more filters on top of this for example
if I just want to see public in the
domain I can click on this and it shows
me public in the domain and then I can
apply for the filters to get more this
thing more granularity now if I want to
edit this report and say add a new page
I can simply choose one of the trade one
of the available witches I can break it
down
there you go so I was able to create
exact same report right in front of you
I can also select a filter and choose
the visibility type they go so i just
created a report in few seconds showing
me how files are getting shared is
outside my company and that's the power
of the query once you have the data
there you can connect it to data studio
run visualizations and customize it in
matter of seconds and that's what that's
what makes this feature very very
exciting and very powerful with this
I'll hand it back 12 great Thank You
Rishi now like to thank you guys for
coming today and if I think if they I
was an admin walking into this session
they're probably be two thoughts on my
mind when I was coming in first question
is how can I secure my company's data
you know what policies do I need to set
up and how can i detect that that's one
piece I hope we've addressed that the
second question that I might ask is what
inspired this lovely carpet choice and
you can't help there I have no idea
[Music]
you
[Music]